Hammer play essentially is a
misdirection play it was actually born
in a Timeout I think we're in Indiana
and George Carlton it's up for me we
would have these plays and have these
huge hands and you know I had good hands
I would always draw a crowd whether I
went hard to drive to the basket
or he posted me sometimes to make a
quick spin move or whatever that started
with the Spurs last two games he's got
27 Lonnie Walker at 12 which was a
playoff career high in game three he's
added another career high here now two
questions here for the Lakers what are
you switching on and off the ball and
then when will you give up
we've got up in the air and throws it
into the hands of Davis it's a jump ball
with 5.1 seconds left
I'm not sure where green thought there
was a window but once he left his feet
he was in trouble and a costly turnover
well they're running a play to try to
get
Thompson down to the corner the old
Hammer play with a back screen on the
weak side but he committed now